[Music]
hi everybody my name's miles ward I'm
the global head of solutions for
Google's cloud platform what that means
is I help people adopt the cloud move to
the cloud I have an incredible privilege
to introduce a friend of mine that I did
not help move to class they did it all
on their own and as a result they really
know all of the wrinkles and the hard
steps that it takes to figure this out
and the results that they've received
are absolutely incredible so I can't
wait for Nils Palmer in who is the
senior engineering manager for nest to
explain to you how they've moved to
cloud are you excited about that sounds
good awesome thank you so much perfect
Thank You Mouse it was pretty amazing
you guys are comfortable perfect last
time I've been this far in front of a
movie theater was like the premiere of
Titanic or something but it's a long
time ago thanks for coming
I'm Neal marinas well said I'm and as
I'm leading Sr yet nest and I'm very
excited to share with you our story how
we migrated on to Google Cloud real
quick poll
who here has migrated to Google cloud
recently over the last couple of years
and I see one hand it's really hard to
see a couple of hands perfect
who here is planning on moving to Google
Cloud that's even more hands so perfect
that's great so let's see how this works
next just to set the stage I just wanted
to share the numbers and the scale of
the service that we are operating to
support nest cameras has anybody here
I'm going to keep this casual like this
anybody here have an S camera at home a
lot of people very cool
thank you first of all so it's it's
really massive and and we were facing a
challenge really on two axes number one
is just a sheer size and the scale so
we're operating on hundreds of thousands
of course recording tens of petabytes of
data and and the data just keeps coming
at like hundreds of gigabits per second
so that's obviously number one getting
data
mound of compute and data over into the
cloud or into Google Cloud the other one
comes just with the service requirement
and the customer promise that we're
making so as you know as customers we're
recording 24/7 and we're doing so and
the customer expects zero skips in their
timeline so they can go back to any to
any particular event the other one is
that we make a customer promise that
they at any given time can open the app
and actually check in on their video
footage and all of that in millisecond
latency so that's what we had to move
pretty big service certainly the biggest
service I've ever worked on let's go
back a little bit where did we come from
so about four years ago pretty much
exactly four years ago Dropcam was
bought by nest and Dropcam really has
been the foundation of what is known as
nest cam today and then six months prior
to that Google bought nest so that kind
of brings up the obvious question like
did they make you do this like did they
make you move on to Google Cloud and I
want to debunk that because it would
actually like cut the talk in half
because we talked about our decision
process so the short answer is no we are
up until recently were an alphabet
company and we call them other bets and
as a bet you really make your own
decisions so and it's also fair to say
like there's good parts of nest that
continue to run on AWS and there's other
bets that are not on GCP that are also
either self hosted or in other cloud
providers so the decision process that
we're talking through is completely
self-made
okay so where were we about four years
ago nest was already a pretty big place
we had thermostats smoke detectors we
had cameras since then we've added more
cameras more thermostats security system
etc etc today I really want to focus on
the camera side of the business and the
camera in AWS was built or the camera
service was built with comedy's AWS
components such as ec2 s3 dynamodb and
then for analytics redshift in Kinesis I
like to use you now
G of of a box of Lego's each clutch
provider has their own you know kind of
kind of tiles and some of them are very
compatible so if you compare like s3 to
Google Cloud Storage they fit very well
together but then there's other services
such as DynamoDB that you know you have
something like that in the Google Cloud
box but you actually need to adjust your
build quite a bit to create the same
customer experience so that's kind of
what I'm gonna walk you through how we
like found replacement technologies for
all of these the other thing I wanted to
say here real quick you know as we were
acquired much smaller operations we were
operating on tens of gigabits of
recording which it was the equivalent of
hundreds of years per day today we
record in the thousands of years every
day of video we're running on on
hundreds of servers and they were still
scaled fairly manually they were
provisioned automatically through puppet
and cloud in it and so forth but
definitely less mature than we are today
but then you know the nest acquisition
was a great opportunity and it really
supercharged the demands on our cloud
infrastructure so number one nests
already had a foothold in Europe and you
know we needed to follow suit so very
quickly we had to move our operations
into you know a global operation the
second one nest allowed customers on
newer cameras to turn their sensors from
720 to 1080p and with all the image
recognition and so forth that we're
doing that actually means you need to
operate on about like twice the amount
of pixels so and last but not least we
have constantly over the last four years
we have constantly improved our vision
algorithms to actually send meaningful
events to our customers so that also
caused a significant increase in just
compute demand so
we were faced with the decision what are
we going to do and let's talk through
how we ended up deciding to go to Google
cloud so without a doubt probably for us
the biggest reason was Google global or
the Google the global nature of Google's
Network and its components so for our
service all the video is obviously
recorded in the cloud but then the video
that is live viewed is actually being
reflected off the cloud so as such it's
actually fairly easy to understand like
the closer you get that compute to the
customer the better the experience is
going to be the lower the latency
they're going to be so as we enter new
markets it's really important for us to
have a presence as close as possible so
Google cloud helps there right if
building and we'll look into that in a
second so building a multi region story
in cloud whether you do it for just
proximity like us or regulatory reasons
or you know quote-unquote just to
achieve resiliency it just seems very
easy from experience it's very easy to
do it with with Google cloud so there
was one the other one was savings so if
you run a business you are obviously
worried about operating costs you are
worried about margins we are one cost
that we're tracking is the cost that it
there were the service cost of operating
a camera this is real numbers without
the actual values but this is how we
have seen the cost of operating a camera
decline over time now I do want to say
it's highly dependent on your use case
so in our use case we actually stripped
everything apart enterprise agreements
our eyes just like stripped out apart
looked at Street pricing compared their
to Google cloud pricing and with that
alone we've seen a 20% decrease in
operating cost now in real numbers that
means tens of millions of dollars for us
and that's just in one year very very
massive
and obviously our finance team is
excited about it but we are too because
like what it actually allows us to do is
fun new features so we are building
additional features and like some of the
features that you see on your cameras
today have been funded through those
kind of costs down efforts that will
continue to drive so Google cloud really
helped us there as well so let's take a
look at the migration approach so in a
nutshell this is what it looks like I
really was hoping this is like a smaller
room so I can show up here but I have a
laser pointer cameras stream into the
cloud from there video is recorded into
s3 and video metadata along with like
any sort of event that we have detected
goes into DynamoDB great
and then the client whether you use your
browser or your phone is you know
rendevouz on the same server and you can
consume the stream or watch recorded
video now when we started off we sat
down with the Google cloud folks and
we're like hey couldn't we just move
that s3 thing down into Google Cloud
storage it's great idea but the way our
public cloud pricing models work it's
like all your inbound bandwidth is free
but outbound isn't so you know it would
have been really cost prohibitive to do
any sort of hairpin turn in a table yes
just to stir it into GCP so what we had
to do instead is like really build up
the entire stack in Google Cloud and
build the necessary abstractions - you
know for a server that is in Google
Cloud to know to talk to Google Cloud
storage and and to spanner respectively
as a replacement for is three and
dynamodb so that took a while but it was
you know it was the way to go and then
the actual migration became trivial so
we updated the database record said you
now belong to Google Cloud and we could
do this one camera at a time which is
really important you now belong to
Google cloud we sent the camera a
disconnect signal the camera doubts back
in connects to Google cloud and stops
recording over there easy and we're done
this works extremely well by the
four new cameras but what about the
cameras that have been recording and a
half data recorded you know assume they
are on a 10 day recording plan so what
we wanted to avoid is a big copy job
because ultimately it would have still
been egress charges so and also if you
imagine it you you know many of you are
users not all the video you have ever
recorded you actually look at it's a
small fraction of the video that we ever
actually playback so and on top of that
the data is actually self expiring so
the you know after 10 days we have a
customer promise that we're going to
delete the data so what we build is a
technology called scatter gathering so
is if a client requests video you know
now connected to Google cloud that is
still stored in AWS we just pull that in
automatically across clouds stitch it
back together and present it through the
API as if it would be all in Google
cloud now it's very specific to our use
case but what I what's interesting here
is you what's interesting here is you
can you can do this with with any
application like even if you have like
you know it's three log processing and
the data is expiring over there you can
easily you know use public cloud api's
securely over the Internet bringing back
the Lego analogy there's no reason why
you you know can't intermingle those
different services so it was kind of a
breakthrough moment for us to really
like keep migration costs under control
all right
next I want to talk about the you know
how we build a global architecture so to
do that I want to talk through real
quick how a camera first connect when
you first power it up it goes through
this routing lookup layer where you know
backed by a load bouncer that
backed by a load balancer which in turn
is backed by compute engine instances
and we do a quick lookup figuring out
where this camera belongs and then
actually connect this camera straight to
the to the owning server of that camera
now very quickly you can add a couple of
regions right and now really try to look
at both ends of this right whether it's
the low bounce on the left side with a
couple of API calls or clicks you can
add compute engines from any region
really to that load balancer and if you
look at it from the right side as well
you know whether it's the global
spaniard storage or you know a global
orgy alike within the geographic region
a Google Cloud Storage bucket all these
things and and you know other services
that I'm not showing such as pops up
just are global in nature making it very
easy to build a global infrastructure
the other thing that's that's important
here and it's not shown is it's really
the same VPC network it's the same
firewalls it's the same public API is
that we've called in the same public API
endpoints to launch these instances it's
really just a matter of like specifying
the launch region of where you launched
your instance and last but not least all
of them are connected through Google's
fast backbones so even if you have you
know cross region traffic you don't have
to deal with VPC peering or anything
like it it just works next we can just
add an entire continent right so going
into Europe for example going into Asia
next you know we're now it's very cookie
cutter to go into new markets and new
regions and you know sre or you know
operations is now no longer in the way
of the business to enter new markets
which is really a great enabler yeah
that's how we build a global
architecture so
next I want to talk there's there's like
three takeaways I think that I want to
talk about and the first one is like
focused on reusable tools so doing a
migration like this it's like a huge
investment so you know in our case we've
written thousands of lines of codes and
at every step in every turn we've asked
ourselves like is this a one-time deal
or is this something we could actually
like reuse in the future so I want to
show you remember scatter gathering how
we brought things from AWS like
on-demand over so imagine like whether
it's like a future feature or something
we do automatic as part of like a dr
strategy or so but let's imagine we're
moving a camera from you know the US to
europe like why wouldn't we want to let
you scatter gathering that we've now
once built to pull in data on demand
from other regions if we had to and then
stitch it together and present it back
imagine a camera you know an owner
moving taking the camera with it you can
take it as far as like in the future
sensing of where that camera is best
connected so again it's just one example
of reusability it's something that we
really really focus on during this
migration
my next favorite topic is to think
outside of the ops box I want to this is
probably the most important thing that I
learned during this migration so I run
sre and I was tasked with getting the
service over to Google cloud but my my
lesson here is like whether you're s re
PE
DevOps net ops make it known within your
organization that this is really a
cross-functional exercise and if you do
it well and you really focus on the
customer you can really build it like a
seamless experience or make the
migration extremely seamless and you
actually end up or possibly and I'll
show that in a better place than you
were before so I want to show two quick
examples number one is for the life you
case so if you do this poorly you can
easily get to a point where like okay we
migrate the camera first of all we try
to avoid migrating a camera while it's
actively being viewed but let's assume
for a second you migrate a camera while
it's actively being viewed you move it
over sender the disconnect signal that
comes back in if a customer is viewing
this camera feed it is you know it turns
black customize to exit the app go back
in and so forth it's frustrating so we
work very closely with the apps
developers to say like hey you know if
we send you a signal that we just
changed regions can you just like
reestablish those spinner for a second
and that's effectively what we did but
it actually now improves the resiliency
in our communication signalling between
apps and clout so it's one example the
other one is around the recording model
so the cameras and this is something
where we worked with the embedded team
again we own end to end of the
communication so we worked with the
embedded team and we use a something we
call backfill so the camera in itself
has a little two-minute buffer so when
we send it the disconnect signal to come
back into Google Cloud it's a five
seconds on the other side in Google
Cloud the camera will negotiate with the
service to say like hey you know where
did you left off recording over in AWS
or anywhere else for that matter and we
are trying to and and then we're
negotiating and stitching the timeline
back together so as a result if you come
back later that day and your camera had
been migrated you absolutely seen no
seams on your timeline which is pretty
neat so again it took a lot of effort to
get there but it's like we were we were
that we were that concerned about the
customer experience doing this migration
and then the other thing is like RER
connecting and do it often if I would
have waited or we would have waited for
Google cloud to provide us with a
replica of what we had in Amazon we
would have never moved right so you do
need to adapt and if you look at the
marketing material very often what I
found is like it scratches the surface
of what the actual performance
characteristics are off their services
and even if you look things like s3 and
GCS they're ever so subtly different so
I encourage as you go down this road I
encourage you to stay you know very
nimble and really embrace that that you
need to make changes a lot so here's a
very simple example that like you can
wrap your head around so the average
recording node in AWS looked something
like that so we're using c3 instance
types and we really like them because
they come for free with these and
awesome and femoral drives super-high
ops 2 times 80 gig we strap them
together and we use them both to you
know spool video before we flush it out
to s3 but we also use it to to keep a
cache of recent video so we don't
actually have to retrieve it from s3
every time a customer requests something
now we're like okay sweet like we can
built the same thing over in compute
engine so we're like oh let's take an n1
standard eight comes with a 30 gig of
ram so really very similar performance
characteristics and we plugged a hard
drive in PD hundred eighty gigs oh sorry
160 gigs and we're like oh this is going
to be great
it worked phenomenally well in QA but
once we actually like put it in like
load under it put it in you know low
tested it it turns out and is like not
the fault of PD we just like its it
doesn't match the the i/o capacity of a
of an ephemeral SSD drive so we're like
okay that doesn't work so next Google
has a similar and this is what I'm
saying like you know both of them check
the check marks they have like a femoral
drives Google has a has a drive that's
you know 375 gigs local SSD you know
it's as volatile it's as fast the
problem is though it's too big it's the
smallest it's a smallest denominator
that you can attach and local SSD the
problem is and it for most customers
it's not a problem because they actually
attach like 10 or so of them to run big
Cassandra notes but in our case if you
operate thousands of these servers it
would have just been a giant waste so we
kind of ruled that out as well and then
we started thinking
like let's take a look at the hundred 80
gigs 160 gigs and see what we actually
use them for so we added instrumentation
around you know you cache hit rates your
cache miss rates and so forth and it
turns out we actually didn't need all
this storage so we ended up with a
machine and this is was all like in a
matter of we err of a week or so so like
again like staying very very nimble we
ended up with a machine that was like an
N one hime m8 that's how it's called so
it just comes with more memory and we
copped out of 25 megabytes sorry 25
gigabyte hard drive and you know it's s
volatile as a local SSD it's has even
big or better IR performance and in the
process we saved a bunch of money as
well because we didn't have to attach
all these additional drives so it's that
kind of thing where you really like once
the rubber hits the road you really need
to make adjustments and embrace that and
be open to that so great so takeaways
this kind of ties back into the hard
drive story don't be afraid to
experiment my number one advice is
invest in good instrumentation like you
want to set the baseline of like what
the customer is experiencing in your old
cloud provider and then you really want
to say with confidence whether you're
moving the needle in the right direction
or in the wrong direction
the other thing I'm feeling fairly
strongly about is forklifts don't work
like you don't want to come in on a
Monday and change DNS of your entire
service I really try to move either one
customer at a time of data I'm in our
case it didn't work due to data
constraints but like if you can one
service at the time have a failback
strategy and so forth we did that more
than once where we you know in the early
phases were moved a couple of cameras
over and then we move
back you know in internal cameras and
then like as I said before like you it's
like hitting six right numbers in the
lottery like you're not gonna pick the
right infrastructure on the get-go so
really I encourage you to stay nimble
and like actually embrace that fact to
to make changes often and see if you
move the needle in one way or the other
that's one the other one is focused on
reusability so I said before it's not a
necessary p/e DevOps problem alone
really tried to focus on the customer
and you you do have an opportunity just
as I showed you to actually come out
with the with it with the service and a
platform that is better and more stable
than it was before you actually went
down this on this journey to migrate to
cloud or to Google cloud and last but
not least save money and have fun with
it it's something that we do it's an our
DNA to constantly like create additional
Headroom for features and we've just
scratched the surface on it like I mean
so stains use discount so you kind of
get for free but then Google has great
knobs to to really drive your
operational cost down so we are looking
very heavily into auto scaling and we're
very excited about preemptable VMs in
particular for some of our workloads to
reduce cost even further
[Music]